la salle g arrive doucement chez nous
pour l'instant seul un opérateur la
propose pourtant ses détracteurs parlent
d'un développement à marche forcée alors
devant les interrogations sur les effets
notamment pour la santé tour métropole
organise une concertation sur cette
nouvelle technologie en parle avec mon
invité bonsoir antoine martin bonsoir
vous êtes adjoint la france un soumise
au maire de tours en charge des services
publics numériques notamment
vous êtes également conseillé
métropolitain avant de parler de cette
consultation vous mener auprès des
citoyens d'abord où est-ce qu'on en est
du déploiement de la 5g dans la
métropole de tours est ce que vous
l'avez vous avez votre mot à dire alors
non nous n'avons pas été consultés par
le gouvernement d'ailleurs le
gouvernement a choisi de faire un
passage en force après la tribune que
nous avons signé avec monsieur le maire
et d'autres élus d'autres maires sur la
demande d'un moratoire à l'échelle
nationale donc le gouvernement est passé
en force et nous retrouvons donc
aujourd'hui avec le commencement d'un
déploiement de la 5g sur l'ensemble de
la métropole notamment d'une 5g assez
spécifique c'est-à-dire elle utilisera
le réseau d'antennes 4g en partageant en
fait la fréquence de la cad j'espère
c'est un peu comme si vous avez
l'autoroute doit 4g l'instant voilà
surtout free vous allez avoir l'ensemble
de la puissance de la 4g qui va être
utilisé en faire une partie de la ba 105
hadji qui va être utilisé par certains
téléphones spécifiquement ayant un peu
en accès premium
on peut dire ça c'est de là qu'est née
voilà une sorte de 4g l'améliorer avec
un accès un accès très bien dans ces
timides ont pour l'instant alors
pourquoi lancer une consultation de
concertation sachant aussi que les
opérateurs bas niveau quand même
et bien comme on peut le voir il ya une
demande au sein de la société pour
pouvoir débattre sur ces sujets là on
peut voir déjà qu'il ya une question
environnementale qui se posent on veut
pas dire aux gens qu'ils doivent trier
leurs déchets qui doit faire un effort
et dans le même temps qu'ils doivent
changer de téléphone portable pour
pouvoir avoir une nouvelle une nouvelle
connexion quelque chose de plus rapide
plus fort plus efficace il ya des
questions sanitaires aussi qui se pose
évidemment
et enfin la dernière le dernier aspect
c'est qu'est ce que l'on veut comme
technologie
aujourd'hui on a le député françois
soumises françois ruffin qui est sort un
livre qui est leur progrès ou notre
progrès et où justement il on se pose la
question savoir quel futur technologique
on veut que
à présent on a toujours vu la
technologie comme étant un facteur de
progrès humain
et depuis quelques années on voit que ce
n'est plus le cas pourquoi ne pas
attendre le rapport de l'ansés simple
agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
de l'alimentation de l'environnement et
du travail qui doit sortir ce rapport-là
ce mois ci où le mois prochain et qui
doit justement trancher cette question
sanitaire et bien ça fait longtemps
qu'on souhaitait faire un débat sur
cette question là mais comme vous voyez
on ad'un des circonstances tallinn terre
un peu spécifique depuis quelques mois
je souhaitais organiser un débat pour ma
part en présentiel et donc aujourd'hui
les circonstances font que à force
d'avoir décalé nous avons fait un débat
en visio en distance yale sur lequel on
a convié à la fois des citoyens des élus
également des associations des acteurs
économiques pour pouvoir débattre et
élaborer des préconisations sur comment
accueillir cette technologie de quelle
manière
comment comment répondre aux questions
environnementales et sanitaires c'est un
ensemble de choses où on va consulter
des experts alors voilà c'est pas ouvert
à tout le monde mais ce que les
téléspectateurs pourront avoir accès aux
résultats de cette concertation tout à
fait déjà les téléspectateurs pourront
avoir accès à l'ensemble des avis
d'experts donc nous allons avoir cédric
villani qui a choisi d'intervenir
nous l'avons invité sur ce sujet là
ensuite une fois que l'ensemble des
participants se seront mis d'accord on
fait un ensemble de préconisations ils
vont revenir au conseil métropolitain
puis dans les conseils municipaux
donc il faudra s'attendre à revoir
encore de la 5g dans les conseils
municipaux de tours et à la métropole de
tout repère en un mot cette technologie
va pas se servir pour notre téléphone
elle va servir aussi par de la médecine
etc
quelles sont les applications alors il
ya tout un ensemble d'applications
souvent les ceux qui sont en faveur de
la 5g met en avant la voiture connectée
la télémédecine
on peut imaginer le fait de télécharger
des films en hd très rapidement sur
votre téléphone portable
il ya tout un ensemble de promesses qui
sont derrière imaginez vous pouvez
prendre le train et avoir un film très
rapidement ou un jeu sur votre téléphone
portable en cours nous ce sera du
confort c'est essentiellement du confort
mais la question est de savoir qu'est ce
qui va changer par rapport à la 4g en
quoi est-ce que vous avez besoin de la
5g pour pouvoir mieux utiliser facebook
twitter tous les réseaux sociaux tous
les youtube
en fait au fond jusqu'ici non il n'y en
a pas besoin soit ouais vous en tout cas
vous avez tranché pour votre part merci
beaucoup antoine martin nous avoir parlé
donc
une déploiement de la 5g chez nous à
tous merci